man that's crazy because that that was a
very special week in comedy
because did you follow robin too no but
i remember
him walking around and saying hi and you
go hi hi and then just he's not good
socially did you ever talk to him
he i i have the same story as you yeah
yeah
robin and chris were making rounds on
oscar week yeah
and it's me sully mccullough upstairs
absolutely we're upstairs at the laugh
factory it's like a thursday
and we're just talking and like sully's
facing the the stairs coming up
and and you just see his you just see
his head kind of like
like that and i'm like what and he goes
it's robin yeah and i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
turn around yeah yeah and he's like hey
how are you
yeah yeah hey um how are you guys and
i'm like what's up robin
and i go uh do you want to go up he goes
oh um
you know the lady up front said that you
guys are uh
there's too many comments i'm like what
who said that said that
like who the fired fire her i know
and then i go i go you will take my spot
sir
i go and first of all i don't know who
the [ __ ] said that to you yeah you can
walk up
anywhere so anywhere on the planet and i
go i go please and then suli said the
same thing um yeah take my spot too
yeah you're good and then we watched
that man go up
[ __ ] amazing amazing
didn't have a set you know i mean he was
practicing because he was introducing
like best animation but he said he was
going to do a set
he wanted to do five minutes before and
he was running his he was running it
and then and then he came upstairs we
hugged he was talking
and his car got towed because you know
those [ __ ] street signs are so good
that's how long it's been since he's
been at the [ __ ] lap he doesn't know
that it's
it's different on sunset now yeah and he
goes oh but it said that it's
available as i go but read it yeah yeah
so uh yeah you know what's mind-blowing
is we don't want to tell you this part
and i i
don't know okay because it's really
special right
um you sucked his dick i sucked it
um no uh so he said he was coming back
he's gonna come back
and this is when i i always say this i
go there's there's levels of fame
right mm-hmm there's famous and then
there's
there's jesus christ yeah you know what
i mean yeah yeah and i'm not even trying
to be funny
yeah you know i mean like and that's
what robin was
yeah he's jesus christ he talks to
multiple generations
and then and then some right so
i'm at the lab factory it's the weekend
right and i'm hosting
right and i'm like [ __ ] is robin coming
back it's like
saggit it's uh i can't remember who's on
the show but all of a sudden
chris [ __ ] rock walks in right
and of course you don't give an
introduction because this crowd has no
idea what the [ __ ] is about to happen
it's going to be complete destruction
right
ladies and gentlemen chris rock this is
when you know the levels
of fame there's famous and then there's
jesus christ
i go chris rock the crowd will not shut
the [ __ ] up
for like five minutes just screaming
people like
toppling over they can't believe it
standing ovation won't sit down this is
chris
[ __ ] rot this is and i want you guys
to google
the when he hosted because i don't know
what year that was but this was
chris [ __ ] rock this is
you know he's on everything and um
anyways
that happens right and then i'm hosting
and i'm like i can't believe it
uh now i put someone else on stage i
can't remember who it was
and then all of a sudden robin's here
oh my god i'm like tonight i'm like am i
hosting this [ __ ]
oh what a night yeah old one a night
right but here's here's
bob saget by the way i i say this all
the time but bob saget
pops up and he's like hey i'm gonna
bring up uh i'm going to bring up robin
and i'm like bob come on man
i'm like please let me bring up robin
he's like no we kind of have this thing
and uh
i'm going to bring my [ __ ] yeah so
bob brings them up right even though i
was a host bob um
i love bob by the way he brings up uh
robin
bobby it's pandemonium i i can't even
explain to you
what happened man it was it was [ __ ]
insane like what chris had was amazing
but this [ __ ] i'm literally camera
phones
running up to the stage taking pictures
of him
and then robbing going i got a camera
too [ __ ] camera ward let's go and then
you start saying
and everyone's laughing at that and
people running you know the stairs on
the side
running down the stairs yeah they gave
they didn't even want to see them
perform
yeah they just wanted to touch jesus
yeah yeah yeah and
man i'm telling you dude it was holy
[ __ ] dude that that guy
wow it was just and and then and this is
how beautiful
he was bob uh bobby he i when he when he
got off and said good night and you know
how you
i have to walk past him and close the
show out and i go i really wanted to
bring you up
i go i go i love you so much but i it
sucked that i didn't get to bring you up
and he goes oh
bring me up again come on bring me up
again
we'll [ __ ] around on stage wow wow
and i and i go ladies and gentlemen
rub it away and the crowd went ape [ __ ]
again and then for like two minutes we
were just
[ __ ] around on stage oh wow it was
man
it was my everything man that was that
was that was my oscar moment
do you can i say it in my thing or no or
not yes because
you were that was long but um
i gotta go so i know i know but i'm just
saying that
i got peace
are you like me where um you know when
you see
somebody that you're a fan of because
it's like
you know i'm supposed to be you know a
comedian
too which i am right but yeah